we're going to make a song that makes
you feel like you can conquer the world
because I had nothing when I was a kid
nothing I've been working on my first
almost 13 you're not going to see me do
things that are the easy play it's just
not going to happen you know you're
going to see me do things that I have no
business doing
hello elimination my name is Evan
Carmichael my were didn't believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so a
total of your journey today I'm going to
learn from singer songwriter producer
and entrepreneur Tom the law and my face
on top pencils number six of my personal
favorite and unless you know which one
is you guys like the best and that's all
the guys are watching each year
something that's pretty resonates with
you please leave it in the comments
below so folks around other people can
be inspired by current apply as well and
also when you write it in as much more
likely to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
and I was in the seventh grade my buddy
moved away to Oregon there was a week
where I went up to go visit him in
Portland
flew up there by myself go to his house
and the whole thing was hey he's going
to be in school on some of these days
this week so you can shadow him to
school or you can hang out until he gets
out of school I shot at him one day and
I'm like this is weird I'm gonna stay at
your house and wait but in his room
there were four things that were very
important a stiff little fingers record
there was an all record the dinosaur jr.
record and there was an electric guitar
so what I did was I would play those
three albums on vinyl and I will go over
and pick up this guitar to keep myself
entertained throughout the day for those
three or four days that he would be at
school until he'd come back and we'd
skate at night and do whatever that
changed my life you know changed my life
the adhering punk rock music and picking
up the guitar something clicked where
it's almost like there's a bunch of
gasoline on the ground and someone
sticks of cigarette it just ignites you
know it's just there's a chemical
reaction that just flipped on a switch
that nothing could take that guitar out
of my hand from that point forward being
in a band you have to constantly
reinvent yourself you have to constantly
be reminded you know how there's someone
better than you every other weekend and
you have to constant your constant
reminded how on you have nothing without
your fans you know so you have to take
into account what they're thinking and
what they're interested in and all those
things matter it doesn't but it doesn't
matter what art you do it does a matter
if it's to make an album or a movie or
book or whatever you have to think
thinking about all those types of things
is poor the hard work involved I mean if
you want to have like a casual life and
you don't want to be in a pan I mean you
never sleep it's really really hard work
you know and you're exhausted all the
time and you're almost always sick and
you're fighting with your business
partners all day long and it's a it's
just how it is but I have a very very
strong work ethic because I had nothing
when I was like
nothing I've been working on my first
time I was 13 I had two jobs when I was
16 you know and um but I would I think
it's a lot of it's probably because I'm
extraordinarily fearful about having to
do what someone tells me to do so I'd
rather be doing everything because at
least no one told me to do that
no I don't know I think when you grow up
as a kid you know you're always looking
for your voice you're always looking for
your independence and always looking to
find out who you are with skateboarding
I mean the transportation person form up
with the kid
we are skateboard we can get out and you
can go some they can't drive it you know
so it's kind of like this is your tool
your vehicle to leave and they're kind
of going okay what's my freedom but it
expanded from just transportation
something you do on your own you don't
need a whole team to play with you you
just do it with you and you can go skate
by yourself and I think that music did a
lot of the same kind of stuff I think
that when you're when you're joining you
know a band for the first time you're
trying to find your voice you're trying
to find that freedom to get in a van and
get out of town you're trying to figure
out who you are by defining it for your
music the way you dress and then you
hang out with it was funny bono once
said that they didn't even know to start
the band u2 until they saw the Ramones
you realize you don't have to shred at
your instrument to be in a band you know
you can get the emotion across in a
different way it was kind of more of
what you're saying and how you're living
not as much as your solos you know and
on guitar so what I learned from being
in a punk rock band is really divested
from getting out there and doing things
yourself I've always been a fascinating
space I used to I always tell people
this because it's one of my favorite
quotes if this space is infinite like
there's no end there's no end to space
then it's infinite the possibility you
know anything you think of right now
could be happening because it's that big
and that was always really exciting to
me because I'm kind of wired to be an
optimist and I'm when I started playing
guitar with these types of rhythmic
trance-like echoes I started to feel
that way I sort of feel like I was
floating through space first thing I did
is I set up the studio in my house so to
be a home for the first time and I put
up these big television
and I was playing all science fiction
films like Blade Runner or 2001 or like
anything I was visually stunning on but
then I also have these Steven Ambrose
books these big coffee table books world
war two pictures and I kept going over
there looking at the space movie and I'm
looking back down at the that the World
War two photos and back to the spaceman
when I was like wow that juxtapositions
gnarly you know like you know here's
like the earth horizon and the Sun
coming up and it's so beautiful and then
here's guys and a ditch bodies
everywhere and I'm kind of going it's at
the same place you know earth it does
both those things and I said what would
it sound like with marching you know
coming into the song or what would it
sound like if somebody got a battalion
of Tanks rolling in as the song starts
and a critter which was my engineer and
co-pilot on all this stuff he pointed to
a file cabinet and he's always just
slammed that file cabinet shut open and
shut I was like all right and so he
grabs a mic and does it and it just hurt
her gonna just hear the mechanics and
this kind of grinding like a metallic
noise with a slam and he put it in there
and they did a thing to it pitched it
down and next thing you know when it's
happening in a rhythm it just sounded
like a million troops stomping on your
face and I was like oh my god you know
I've never heard something like that in
a song and next thing you know we were
doing that on all the songs um we found
something that was unique to do which
was um you know it's sound design you
see in movies all the time it sounded i
but sound design crafted into a song and
four songs into that writing we were
something called the adventure and not
just that was on that was a
life-changing moment for me but we put
some rocks in a shoebox and we rolled
the shoebox around with all these
pebbles you know and then we grabbed
that and created a rhythm out of it and
so when we added some stomps in this
rolling box of rocks
created this grindy kind of rhythm and
then we added a riff to it that was a
very simple riff kind of sad sounding
but I didn't know what I was going to
play for the main song you know so we
started with the rhythm then put a riff
and I was like okay so where does it go
from here so I stomped on the pedal in
time and I was four hours straight
sitting at the computer I think there's
footage of this of the documentary we
made then you can show it right here
[Music]
[Music]
bring some rhythms enemies I think
that's what happened for years and for
me for later right we go to song I'm
sitting at the computer and it just kind
of starts to starts to happen here will
dry on the song in the moment it was
something that gave you the chills up
and down your arms and I remember
stopping and looking at occurs I host oh
we got something
I remember during writing the words
actually got a friend whose wife left
him
I'm just figured that she can find
something better and you'd love dare I
remember him saying I don't know if
you'll ever know what it's like to love
somebody so much more than that will
ever love you is what he said to me so I
remember feeling so beat up from
everything I was going through with the
whole blink situation and trying to find
a new identity and all that kind of
stuff and then my friend says that to me
and I was like then we're going to make
a song that makes you feel like you can
conquer the world that night after I
sang it I remember sitting in the studio
at 2:00 a.m. was at my house my family
to sleep and I was listen this thing
about half would this thought are these
tears in my eyes and I was just I felt
like there's something magical happening
that happens to me every once in a while
or I'm a part of something artistically
where I get kind of overwhelmed
emotionally and feel like I'm really
onto something that's important not that
I think it's like great or better than
anything else or that it's going to be
I've been giant or big that's because I
feel like it touches on something that's
important to me and it's in it like
grabbed ahold of like a nerve and it's
just gripping it and I could feel it and
it's like electric waves your body
doesn't happen on every single thing but
it happens every so often and then you
kind of go wow this is what I was meant
to do with this one little thing you
know and I'm that song was one of them I
think I learned over the past handful of
years that what I really enjoyed about a
band wasn't being on stage it was just
the idea that I'm involved somehow and
leading a group of people to feel
something at the same time I thought
that was really cool that's what I kind
of dissected I was because I was doing a
lot of sales doing a lot of things like
I was equally interested in a lot of
different things besides just music and
so a lot of people are wondering why
would you not want to be on a big stage
doing all this stuff and I I just walk
out do I Instagram this my supposed to
go on Instagram and tell you all this
thing all these things that I feel about
because you know I don't you know and
but really what
boils down to is I I have a pre wild
imagination and I have a few set of
skills that I've developed not only
inspiring artists or leading people or
putting business models to things or
being entrepreneurial and and also
understanding I'm not really good at any
one thing but I'm definitely good at a
bunch of different things and I kind of
figure I said you know it might be a
really good place for me to sit in the
middle of a bunch of artists that come
together that that can do something a
bit more revolutionary than want each
artist doing one thing on their own yes
and um that's what I came
his record is a very important place it
was the most famous record store in San
Diego and one of the most famous in the
country when bling first started I drove
around about a 20 mile radius from the
floor and I broke into every high school
at night and I made blink flyers and I
put him in every single locker at all
these high schools that we were playing
at the club downtown at that point in
time everyone in San Diego wanted to
support their local bands it was just a
really big theme so because I put those
flyers in those lockers we ended up
having on our first show out of big club
all the people came and we had enough
people that watched us that the guy that
owned the club invited us the following
week to play on the big stage so what we
did is not only pulled that show we
rushed in made a really quick recording
and it was our first recording the
little Buddha statue wanted people
commonly refer to that record as Buddha
we made that to sell here in this store
so we would put five tapes in at a time
there's at the time where tapes are
selling and every week we would call up
and they're over gone with a comb a
super buy more they're gone then we gave
them 10 they're gone they're give them
20
next thing you know we sold thousands of
these tape cassettes Auto lose record
and then we got our start on it was a
you know little suburban kid we had a
dream to be in the punk rock section and
I'm here now looking at all these things
I grew up on and it is so insanely
important to me
my inspiration usually comes from once
the music for this song is more or less
closer being completed I'll just try and
find in an emotional current in it that
makes sense I'll either identify with it
and write exactly like it or try and
write the opposite two good questions I
think it's different for every artist
you know they always say you know I
write the words first and and but not
not for myself I like to write the music
first because to me is like the
foundation of the building you build on
the top of it how much have you changed
as a creative person a lot well I'm
learning so much I mean I mean I'm
learning so much we're doing um when
when I come up with a good idea I stick
with it that's the difference I I can
come up with a lot of ideas that anyone
can you know when I come up with
something oh you know what this is
something that's capable of me growing
and I still will like this is this is
something that's big enough and
ambitious enough that in four years from
now if I really want to become a space
engineer and build spaceships I could
probably put those spaceships and the
movie or the book or something you know
yeah that's kind of how I think come up
with projects that can last long time
and grow and then as I grow I'm still
interested and get created um so I yeah
but I plan for that I plan for my
evolving I ideas I think my biggest
issue is I don't actively go out and
search for admiration for people or to
explain what I'm thinking the people or
to validate my actions so I think what
what it's the first rule in politics
you're supposed to define their
candidate for them before they can
define themselves and what happens to me
is that the fans good in the bad and the
good that press they have to define me
before I go out there and do it and what
happened is is they've defined me in
such a way probably in many places that
is inaccurate
you know I don't think people know that
I listen to scholars every single night
before I go to bed I put it on my
nightstand and listen to lectures I
don't think people know that I read
books and physics I don't think people
know that I'm totally still fascinated
by jokes even though I'm doing so as
those things you know I don't think
people know that my favorite thing in
the world outside of being with my
family is sitting with my Great Dane and
my German Shepherd dog Beach you know
and looking at the sunset I don't think
people know that I'm still completely
fascinated with skateboarding and my son
is so into baseball that my way of
relating to both is wearing Nike SB
which is Nike Skateboarding I don't
think people know that's why I'm wearing
Nike and certain Instagram posts because
it's a way for me to connect with my boy
but also still have a foot in the
skateboarding world from which I came I
don't think people know that I'm
completely immersed in trying to
understand ancient religions and and you
know why we are the way we are and why
we're warring with each other and
probably don't know that I think I have
a solution one of those guys that like
to look at the biggest thing ever oh I
bet you I have a way to fix it which is
the biggest jerk ever but that's how my
brain thinks the only thing that takes
me away from my maddening thoughts is if
I'm learning something for me what I do
is I learned something and how do I turn
that into an art project so it's a mod
fiction book or it's a documentary or
it's a lecture and what does that look
like as an animation what does that look
like in a song what does that look like
as a feature film what does that offered
has a story that has all those things in
it that's a challenge and that keeps my
mind at ease I should tell mark and
blank that I would admire him because he
was always satisfied you know would
blank like it it satisfied him that it
was an incredible thing and we were
given such an incredible thing and we
were so lucky to have it and all these
are things and I and I I agree with all
those things but for some reason it's
not stopping my desire to go out
and learn more and try more and push
myself more and be surrounded by other
people that I find are completely
fascinating um you know you're not going
to see me do things that are the easy
play it's just not going to happen you
know you're going to see me do things
that I have no business doing and
sometimes it's music sometimes with
novels
sometimes it's feature films or
animations or weather sometimes it's all
those things but at the end of the day
I'm still just a very normal kid from a
broken family in a shitty little
suburban town and that should just prove
to everybody that they can do it too
when it comes to tattooing there's
definitely been a learning curve I
didn't start out a master of my craft
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
the tattoo artist and client
communication is essential
all right math it's all gone check it
out there was always more you some
people compare me to Monet some to man a
Sun Picasso but I think I've developed a
style all my own all right tell me what
you think this one here art is a journey
not a destination I'd never want to be
perfect at the dead-end street
all right we're all done take a look at
that Oh
Oh
they design so much watching amazing
city because Piper's free oxygen so this
is a massage Pervez do you want me to
profound facts check out the link in
description you can go and cast both
alpha let us know which clips resonated
and most of you what let's make an
occasion this video and immediately
apply to your life or to business
somehow leave it in the comments below
real interest is what you have I also
want to give a quick try to Jason
pharmacy cap and Yuki thank you guys so
much you're putting up a couple of minds
book at the bookstore and close that
picture to your social channels I really
appreciate your support and I'm really
glad you enjoyed it we thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in using
company peace to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where is much love
[Music]
[Music]
you should follow your passions and they
should make sure you do something about
[Laughter]
the density love your work harder and
I actually take feedback really well I
think but it has to be from you have to
be with people you respect and that you
really genuinely think that they make
good decisions you know it's so much
easier when you can trust the personal
man yeah when that person looks me in
the eye and said like it kind of sucks
what you just did you go he means it and
it's like a you know I agree with them
but you know um and that's where it
works so you have to you know right you
have to get people that you really
respect that you've built up the trust
and and you empower each other and you
and you can can really really get it
done and strong debate as a part of it
but if you have it you know if you have
intelligent individuals it's not hard
yeah